Hey, this is really interesting.
There's a few Republican governors who have
been ignoring, if not completely abandoning
Donald Trump when it comes to dealing with
the virus in their states.
And their popularity has absolutely exploded.
I'm talking mostly about Ohio Republican Governor
Mike DeWine.
He's done a pretty good job of handling Corona
virus from day one, although more recently
there are some concerns about the policies
he's rolling out.
But he's mostly been following health experts
and not Donald Trump and his popularity has
soared.
We also have been looking at how Maryland
Republican Governor Larry Hogan has been dealing
with the virus.
And then our own governor here in Massachusetts,
Charlie Baker, a Republican as well, has been
doing a pretty good job.
And the reason that we care about this is
that the November of 2020 elections are in
many ways referendums.
That's the way.
It's not referenda.
I looked it up, referendums on Donald Trump.
When we look at the Senate race in North Carolina
with Republican Thom Tillis or we look at
Martha McSally in Arizona, or you look at
Susan Collins in Maine, these are in large
part adjudications of the Trump regime.
And so far, it's not going particularly well
for those Republicans.
Many Republicans have been afraid of contradicting
or crossing Donald Trump because they're afraid
it might be bad for their local and state
races.
Trump might target me.
It could be really, really bad.
But what we're seeing is that Ohio Republican
Governor Mike DeWine has absolutely split
from Trump and he is hugely benefiting from
it in terms of approval, in terms of popularity.
And this may be a signal for twenty, twenty
six months away.
We can't say for sure, but it may be a signal.
What did Mike DeWine do?
Mike DeWine lockdown down Ohio early before
other Republicans took it seriously, before
Donald Trump was even taking it seriously.
He's been doing regular briefings that are
actually fact based and they attract Democrats
and Republicans in Ohio and even nationally.
People are watching these, much like Andrew
Cuomo's briefings.
Conservative activists and business leaders
have been pressuring DeWine to do what Trump
wants, start reopening, do all this stuff.
And DeWine just hasn't done it.
And he's been listening to the health experts.
He also came out in favor of a mail in primary
late last month.
Trump has been viciously opposed to mail in
voting and then more recently this week.
DeWine has started to loosen up some of the
guidelines as businesses can start opening.
Masks are recommended six feet, separation
is recommended for workers and customers.
And for a while before this, 30 or more Republicans
in the state legislature were demanding that
DeWine open everything right away and he didn't
do it.
Living with Trump and his approval on Corona
virus is 85 percent.
His trustworthiness rating is eighty nine
percent on Corona virus.
You don't get those numbers with just Republicans.
He's taking testing seriously.
He says they're going to roughly triple testing
by the end of the month in Ohio from 7000
a day to 20000 a day.
And what's interesting is that when we look
at Maryland and Massachusetts, Republican
governors in blue states, you kind of have
to, as a Republican governor, follow what
your liberal state legislatures want you to
do.
Massachusetts has a Republican governor and
Charlie Baker, but a very left legislature
and a relatively left voting public.
So it's not surprising that Charlie Baker
is doing more.
What our state wants rather than what Trump
wants.
But Ohio, it's certainly a battleground state.
But it's not a left wing stronghold of any
kind.
So you might imagine that what Mike DeWine
has done in abandoning Trump would be far
more risky, but it has worked here in Massachusetts.
Charlie Baker, former CEO of a big health
insurance company.
I didn't vote for him.
I'm not looking to have more and more governors
be former CEOs of health insurance companies.
But Charlie Baker knows how to delegate.
He knows how to trust experts and he knows
how to look at data.
Remember that Dr. Burke's laughably claimed
that Trump looks at data and makes decisions
by assimilating the information.
We all knew it was B.S..
What we want to see is governors actually
do what the wine has been doing.
To some degree, what Charlie Baker and Hogan
have been doing.
I'm hopeful that as a result, on May 18th
here in Massachusetts, Charlie Baker will
be able to announce some loosening of certain
guidelines.
If the numbers keep improving.
Yesterday here in Massachusetts, we had only
1.4 percent case growth.
That's really low.
We had a week of about 3 percent daily case
growth.
That's really not bad.
So competence is important.
Ideology is less important here.
Armed protesters aside, for the most part,
we've seen people across the country approve
of competence, even across party lines.
Massachusetts voters overwhelmingly pleased
with Republican Charlie Baker despite being
a blue state.
Ohio voters, Democrats and Republicans, nearly
90 percent approval on a corona virus.
Trustworthiness for the Republican governor
who has abandoned the doctrine of Donald Trump.
Again, this may be a big signal for how November
of 2020 may go.
Hopefully, we don't know.
We've got to count every single vote.
We have to cast every ballot.
But that is the upside to what we are seeing.
We'll have continued coverage of this on the
David Pakman show Instagram page at David
Pakman show.
Follow me while you're there at Davis.